alright we're live welcome to another
google+ hangout today I'm excited to
have Jen de Fanti see the fantasy the
baby copywriter episode 9 back on Jen
how you doing I'm great thank you big
big news in Jen's world yes yes I quit
my full-time job so I'm going to be
doing copywriting full-time working for
myself now hundred percent so I'm
totally freaking out but it's good
totally freaking out I feel like you
need to add some like some effects on
their house that sounded like that yeah
we got the effects happening yeah cool I
mean it's been a while since our last
update what's yeah I think since March
so so what's been going on well has it
been since March Wow where has time gone
well that's part of it is I haven't you
know I mean I've been slowly building up
my Twitter base I've been pretty
consistent with that I've added a few
more videos some of them are kind of
more personal um and continue to do a
little bit of my book fantasy book
videos and then a couple of copywriting
ones i think since we met in March and
then I started a new series when I
announced that I uh you know I took the
leap and put my job and so I'm going to
be I thought I do like another thing
once a week where I talk about what I've
done to build new business and how it's
working for me so I thought that'd be
great for any other copy writers who
want to follow along and I want to see
what I do and what worked for me or
anybody else's job list and now China
this is the jobless in Portland series
right yes exactly job was in Portland
yeah yeah cool I mean so the last am I
looking at my notes from last time uh it
was the last thing railways keep up a
regular schedule right yeah I kind of
didn't do that very well yeah that's
part of why I quit from frankly is
because I just felt like I wasn't able
to invest enough time into myself and my
business and I really wanted to do that
so um you know when that don't have as
much control over my schedule it's
harder to do that so
so yeah this is part of the thing I'm
gonna establish a regular schedule now I
better anyway well you had you had one
from three days ago and one from
yesterday on the channel so that's good
that that's the one that's some recent
stuff the other the last one is a month
old after that so yeah progress the
lease here though that's good um yeah
again the biggest thing for that is now
figuring out a schedule right so some
dank you're looking at the for a memory
serves me otherwise so if you want to do
you know you're talking with you in two
series a week now ah great you know
might be ambitious considering our
history it might be it might be but I'm
gonna have a lot more time at least in
theory I like it uh so you're gonna do
one per week on the on the jobless
obviously homeless homeless jobless yeah
tablas Portland and then one for a week
on what on the condo copywriter the
copywriting right and then i'll probably
still do book ones in between there up
you know i'd love to do at least once a
week on my book 12 but you know that's
that's really more uh you know a
long-term project so it's just whenever
I feel it you know actually I love to
get back to doing that once once a day I
actually started that going once a day
which was awesome for me to get used to
making videos and learning how to edit
them better and faster but I haven't
kept that up so now I want to go back to
that again but I'm not gonna like be too
ambitious too crazy because I gotta get
in business too yeah I mean and those
other ones can be short and quick to
they don't have to be super polished and
you can mix it up right yeah yeah that's
a good suggestion mmm um okay so for the
jobless in Portland 1 i'd love to see
have uh let me let me do a screen share
here so everybody can see what i'm
looking at you sure uh entire screen oh
there we go youtube
let's find you it's not much you don't
have your you don't have a name yet do
you like I do I cuz i signed up before
they changed the rules so I I do it's
like um I want to say it's me video so
much let's see I found you here oh she's
showing me I click on about video so
much yeah there you go video so much
good job yeah with you know so much okay
um so this is what we're talking about
the job was in Portland I love for that
series too I like the name okay uh I
think each episode should be called
something okay just like in TV yeah each
episode is called something yeah so like
episode one could be I quit my job right
most important one there's something
right yeah you use your use your skills
to that's what you're great i just
coming up with names and titles and
writing exactly um and i would
definitely put that at the front not not
at the end okay um cuz look I'm look at
the other one you have like book fantasy
episode 39 dance breathe right yeah
switch that up dance breath right book
fantasy episode 39 so you lead lead with
the more interesting title OIC so lead
with the episodes are those actual yeah
episode title and then follow with a
series yeah okay I was wondering about
that actually okay are you given options
on the on the thumbnails to or not yet i
don't think i am yeah i was just gonna
ask you about that cuz i now it just
gives me three to choose from I don't
know if there's a way to to do that how
many what do you have to do you have a
servant of subscribers or something
through YouTube you all you get invited
to be a partner I don't look I'll show
you mine a good as if i go to videos
getting over a cold yeah I'm sorry um so
like these are all custom thumbnails
right okay well this is an interview I
did just today you know this was us
actually talking and it looks pretty
ghetto right right right i know it was
give me like closing my eyes my mouth
open or something yeah i mean i disguise
built on you know 150 million dollar
business so i wanted that to come out
more in the thumbnail so you should have
an option here as the fourth option it's
a little link that says custom thumbnail
uh let me see if i can find one where I
haven't already done it just so you can
see because all of these have already
thought this one's a good one so this
one I haven't done a thumbnail for okay
and then you upload the thumbnail is
that what you do yeah so here this is
custom thumbnail ah ok and then you
click on that and then I'll just load up
your your file manager and you go find
the picture okay you save it to your
local drive and then upload it here
gotcha a want to do how do you find it
here if you click on so I'm with the
channel yep then what I'm gonna go to
monetization okay ah there might be
something here that says um you monetize
like you want to do you want to join the
partner program okay so i would look at
that so channel and then monetization
and see if there's anything that lets
you going once you're part of that
program even if you never monetize the
videos then that lets you um add
thumbnails okay your own custom
thumbnails yeah otherwise you're picking
the best of the three and the three they
always seem to find the worst
they do awesome all pictures ever they
total they do yeah um I mean eventually
be great to have custom thumbnails with
you know a logo for each one like
jobless and Portland has its own series
and yeah right sometime in the future
but but most important is getting the
content up to start yeah missing me
what's missing me I've been seeing that
one yet um that's a new one that's one
that i posted because I I wrote um it's
a it's a piece that I did for my dance
group that i'm in okay we did a
performance on mom's day okay four of us
it was called seasons of a woman and so
four of us did readings for each one of
the seasons and so that was mine which
was for spring and I just thought it
would be kind of cool to share with
people um you know it's just another
kind of writing that I do oh cool yeah
yeah it's gonna the more personal video
but I just thought it was you know I
thought it was be kind of cool to share
cool yeah i mean i'm a big fan of always
adding some personal content in yeah it
never does as well as the other stuff
but for your for the fans that will come
it makes them really tied to you in a
much deeper level so right i make you
try putting that so the last one you did
for your copywriting business is this
one the storytelling yeah the
storytelling selling it's probably most
pretty yeah great so even though a nice
i would switch it like storytelling
selling then dash fantasy copy okay um
it might even be I might even look at
the titles uh storytelling selling like
I wonder if you switch to something like
how to sell using stories right I'm like
if that if that might is it helps you
with your keywords to ya story telling
selling sales north of sales is they're
sore tongue selling isn't right okay
look even so kind sales
it's not este it's a third one out there
so yeah um look you're not gonna get a
lot of you're not gonna get a lot of
hits there yeah to sell how to sell
drugs nice Wow paypal or hug how to sell
or hot Atari got it pal stories or how
to use story no so like this is what
I'll do when I'm coming up with titles
yeah interesting i'll use a google it so
the youtube auto-suggest cuz these are
things that people are typing yeah and
so if nobody is typing these then I'm
fine I'm not gonna get all our search
traffic for it okay then you're relying
on your subscribers only and you know
you don't have a lot of subscribers I'm
even me like I've 46,000 subscribe do
something which is peanuts compared to
what it could be so good titles i mean
ii know the importance of good titles
but this is a good way to to be able to
do it yeah that's a good hint i like it
i'm curious to what you think about my
the job was in Portland I was going back
and forth between that because I feel
like it's kind of catchy I let you know
I am jobless in Portland but I also
wonder if I should talk a little bit
more like somehow include copywriting in
there for those people who are copy want
to become like coverage I don't know I
just I couldn't decide I was going back
and forth uh I think if you have your
other series regularly going up uh-huh
then it's okay okay like keep this about
make it one about you and your business
and what you're doing okay and that
doesn't necessarily have to be every
week um but I would definitely have the
other one every week like that's the
most important one is your your thought
leadership piece yes okay the guy had to
pick one or the other would always pick
the fantasy copy series over everything
else okay
perfect it's educational and it also
showcases your new as a leader right as
an expert yeah all right Portland one uh
is also educational you know maybe
different audience but educational and
to see what you're doing and it's very
personal um doesn't showcase your
expertise nearly as much uh but I mean
that's okay just as long as the fantasy
copy series is going out you'll have
some success with it yeah I agree yeah I
think it's just to go yeah you're right
it will be a different audience tell
it's an audience that maybe you know
wants to become a cop right or two that
can learn something new so good um it
says it's going live but I'm not seeing
the stream anyway it's fine weird okay
yeah I don't know we've had some tech
issues and getting there are calls going
up and not as its shown at this joint um
okay great so consistency with the
schedule I mean you've had great growth
in your Twitter side but the YouTube one
is what's falling behind yeah you spent
a lot of time like every day you're on
Twitter you're posting something that's
usually good stuff and I'm respond to it
um yeah you do so it's yeah applying
that same consistency to to you too
exactly and my facebook too i actually
it's funny i'll have random like burst
of like all of a sudden a bunch of
people look at my facebook page and then
i got a couple followers i don't know
where that's coming from if they're
coming from you know my youtube channel
or if they're just finding me through
you know a couple of posts that I've
written right I'm not exactly sure it's
kind of interesting but anyway yeah I
don't know if you can look at that in
the Facebook analytics there may be a
way I don't dive too deep on the
Facebook analytics okay if you're really
curious and maybe away on your back into
look into it what about your what about
your newsletter like your subscribers
are they where are they coming from I
mean are they getting some kind of free
thing from you and then I know that's
what a lot of people tend to do like
I'll give away this free
book and sign you my newsletter and I
feel like more people for you probably
coming from your YouTube is that right
or were they coming from um that's a
good question uh the signup page is
always from my from my website so even
if you come from YouTube you're directed
to my website to sign up for the
newsletter right at the end of my videos
now I have people go to my newsletter or
something that I say join the newsletter
there's a link that people can go to ok
um so people are clicking through on
those uh I don't I guess I could
probably tell if I look through my
analytics what their path was that they
came from a youtube link and then
something newsletter but I'm I haven't
dug that deep in the analytics um but
its a mix between my website traffic in
the youtube traffic as I youtube traffic
grows um then then that'll grow to write
them youtube this month for me is gonna
be around 700,000 views or something
like that oh my god just this one seven
yeah seven hundred thousand what we're
on track works that's amazing yeah I
mean but I mean but it's also the
consistency of always putting up videos
right you for like two up a day right or
more but me to up a day every day that's
amazing is that are you doing I know
you're doing your new Express oh yeah is
that like a third or as I just one of
the two now uh I started and I mean this
may be helpful for you to and planning
your thing I started I started and
suppressed because I was frustrated that
I wanted something to make me think
bigger in the morning like the wake up
and like boom you got a shot of
entrepreneurship I exposed to bigger
ideas and that's not in my environment
right now and I wish somebody created
that and I told my friends is that a man
I wish is something out there i just i
kept telling other people i wish
somebody made this and i thought you
know what this is ridiculous i'll just
make it right so it's a selfish thing I
made it myself but I wanted to be
exposed to these ideas every morning and
people responded well to that right it
was like it was this missing
in the market and so every weekday
that's the interesting series where it's
a famous entrepreneur message and then I
comment on it yeah weekends I have a
top-10 collection of quotes so it's
still kind of the same inspirational
message how I break it down is more than
is inspirational morning is the
motivating you get some hands-on like
tactical but it's more like give you a
boost kind of thing to start your day
and afternoons are the more tactical you
know sign into somebody's question how
do i how do I you know how do i launched
my youtube channel or something right
like it's really specific and i'll give
not as much motivation but more here's
the how-to steps um okay okay the
morning inspiration afternoon tactical
tips and so far it's working out like
last month I had five hundred twenty
thousand views this month and it's going
to be over 700 yeah so amazing is that I
record for you every month is a new
record know what the growth is a new
record it's it's pretty insane um even
the subscribers like I'll all be at 75
76 hundred subscribers new subscribers
this month relax I was 45 miles almost
doubling the new subscribers yeah I'm
look um no I'm excited I mean I'm not
millions of all right I have 40 45
thousand subscribers or something yeah
but you know I'm on my path to your on
your path I'm on my path or I'll trying
to get the bigger places but that series
definitely helps both of those series
and having that definition helps as well
so yeah if you're consistent to like you
know Sunday's you launch something or
Monday's you launch something and it
helps you schedule what you're doing it
also helps people watching know to
expect a certain video on a certain day
ready for it yeah yeah I was just
thinking about that as you were saying
that because I there are a couple people
that I do follow that I like I know they
come out with there's every Tuesday or
whatever and so I go and I look yeah so
um and it's interesting i wonder if i
could do i like your idea of doing
something tactical and then something
inspirational cuz i tend to do my
copywriting videos are more they're kind
of more tactical usually yeah ah so
maybe i do try and mix up by doing
something maybe every other week or if I
couldn't somehow get to a week um do
something kind of inspirational or more
philosophical around copywriting I mean
you post a lot of great stuff on Twitter
your posting quotes you posting articles
there's a lot of great uplifting moving
thoughts there that that I like I I
enjoy following you on Twitter not just
because I know you and you know how can
you and working together but like I
actually like oh I wonder what Jen's
posting right yeah yeah come on so some
of that content those quotes those
thoughts could be turned into a more
uplifting kind of video yeah okay for
sure or lessons that you learn from from
whatever article whatever quote oh I do
want to you know uh man vacations right
right I know it's elves up for a
scheduled that'll work uh so whatever
feels right i mean i think the
copywriting that's the most important
one that serious has to continue at
least once a week the other is if it's
an inspirational on if it's Hawk you're
seeing homeless jobless in portland ah
the personal you know dancing wands
whatever um I think you should kind of
pick one or have them rotate or
something because I think committing to
more than two a week given yeah in the
past is even two week is a stretch but i
like it and it's a good stretch goal
let's make sure we hit it and you
definitely stressed out in burrito but
yeah those inspirational ones can really
help we're getting a question from serve
games a lot wants to know
how long we've been doing YouTube well
I've been doing it for five years or
something kind of I started off not
doing it often once a month or something
and now when we're active and generally
when did you start oh my gosh I was just
I was just wondering that I think maybe
about a year ago maybe I'm gonna go look
and see when my first one is that I
posted ah because I can't remember it
was about a year ago I mean I really
didn't start doing it more regularly
until maybe the fall last year it seems
like um but i think i think i did my
first one member when i did that for
that I'm Turin company the lingerie
company right I think I did that um you
know about this time last year yeah so I
mean so then to answer your question sir
games a lot Jen was about a year I'm
about five years and I think well you'll
find with a lot of youtubers are when
they when they first started it's not
necessarily when they actually got
committed to it like people test out the
waters right even jen is posting you
know one or two a month just testing out
the waters before really getting serious
and I think for me I started getting
serious maybe two years ago I don't
think i was posting to a day two years
ago maybe one a day but that's still
pretty yeah pretty ambitious yeah yes
yeah and to add a has maybe been a year
of that but but it's every day like
right you've been three days off in the
past year where I didn't have a video
for like a technical reason or something
but right right consistent yeah yeah
because I do all the work myself I know
you have more of a team and more of a
system definitely more of a system than
I do um and yeah third time so I'm like
oh it post is tomorrow but then like
I'll get a glitch you know in iMovie or
all it just takes me longer to edit than
I expected to so so yeah sometimes it
just takes me longer yeah I mean I do
have a team and that helped me get to
two videos a day instead of doing one
video you know a week right and I just
hired a cameraman so I've got we got one
person in research one person doing
editing and one person filming me so I
can spend more time just being in front
of the camera awesome but I've still
done videos where I just i turn on my
I've can so i started a new series about
my book oh you did write in the book and
I got asked I asked my audience hate you
guys want me to write it do a series
about my book and the journey that I'm
going on right in my book and and of
course if I just said that everybody say
yeah I ever want to hear it but I also
said you know if I make this series I'm
isn't taking one video away because I'm
not now adding more videos i'm taking my
video way and the response was still yes
we want to hear it and so I thought for
that series it's going to be a lot more
casual like I'm gonna film it where I'm
actually writing so what I right sitting
on my floor no really you catch I don't
know why they call it so I filmed the
video there and I just turned on my
laptop my webcam you know it's not going
to be edited like don't have the intro
whatever but it's not going to be cut
edited I didn't use a cameraman
obviously for there's no research I just
got in front of the camera and started
talking yeah and so those are fine too
right like you can do those videos you
don't have to thank all it's not I don't
have a team like the most important part
is you on camera everything that I add
to it the effects all that help but it's
look at this video goes up right there's
no editing at all there's no intro at
all it's just us having a conversation I
agree I gradually gray it's not just a
team it's it's like you said earlier
it's the commitment its commitment to do
it and just do it I totally agree that's
really where it comes from and you could
also do an interview series not going to
now want to add more to your place thank
you I did not do but uh you know the
people that you look up to or the people
that you're you're sharing their tweets
I think it was the person you had today
ah yeah Laura Ling Laura Ling ya sultan
her you know she's got like six hundred
Twitter followers or something right
yeah not like some not like Oprah or
something right right well you could
reach out to her and say hey I want to
do an interview with you on my youtube
channel and talk about whatever the
message was in that tweak yeah and that
way you're bringing other people on as
well and there
learning about who you are can help
spread your message in my chair with
their audience when it's up and you
might learn learn stuff along the way
that you can you know get inspired to
put into your your business as well yeah
so I get this another idea easy way to
fill content without with is zero work
except showing up right right like today
I've done three hangouts already this is
my third one so I get three new videos
on my youtube channel and the only work
that I'm doing is showing up and
pressing the cord and got a new video
yeah um and as they build an audience to
people so to ask questions right like
Sir games a lot asks us a question I had
questions and the other on the other
videos too just a good audience
development kind of tool when you get to
learn in the process as well I agree I
love it when people ask questions
pathetic then you know what they're
interested in wow that's awesome anyway
it's just I'm gonna try like not
necessarily out of my plate but maybe I
could just try interview or two and if I
if I really like how it turns out like I
keep doing them I think what I might do
what am I thinking about for you is is
two videos a week one video always is
the copywriting video continue to the
series make it make sense I might I
might try to make it flow little more
cuz now it jumps yeah you and you
started with the call to action and then
you're so like having a serious makes it
easier people to follow along uh-huh and
then um you can even start over like
start down whatever love you have your
seven things right this yeah seven step
start at number one right now and
underneath each one you have points
right and right like each one under each
of the seven points you have sub points
right yeah exactly each sub point is its
own video so those seven topics made
lead to what 40 videos yeah I don't know
whatever it is like that's almost a
year's worth of videos uh by the time
you get to call the action again it'll
be over a year plus you'll be way better
at it like your new call to action video
would be way better than
you have before so just start over and
make a new series allows people to to
follow along I like it that's a great
idea because it is very sporadic on
there I might have some videos from like
a long time ago and there's my book
videos in between so they can take
people wild even find them so yeah um
yeah okay cool I'll start over I dig it
one video a week on the copy fantasy
copyrighted in one video a week
something else okay if interview jobless
and Portland a book update personal
update whatever you're feeling Kappa
provide you're going with put it in
there like okay I'm not going crazy and
wanting now to do five videos a week and
then you burn out and don't do anything
right so you do the tube a week and
you're consistent okay a couple more
questions coming in Nicholas how do you
make an income with so views I mean I
find your content fascinating but
YouTube can't your main source of income
youtube is not main source of income and
it's not Jen's main source of income ah
the point of what we're doing is using
for exposure right so I use YouTube to
get speaking gigs and corporate gigs you
know i'll charge ten thousand dollars
per speaking gig that I go out to and a
lot of the companies find me because of
YouTube they find my videos they're
searching for entrepreneurship whatever
my channel comes up and what we were
just talking about oh I don't know
Nicholas if you're on earlier but we're
trying to have jen's videos tagged and
using the proper titles that are very
search friendly so that potential
clients of hers or watching the videos
would be interested in looking at them
and potentially hiring her right
building Jen up as an expert which she
is is just making that more well-known
and having people be able to find her
yeah and I can even use links to my
videos as I am prospecting new clients
too yeah that's great like show off your
expertise show what you can show you can
do show your thoughts yeah leverage
the continent sound but yeah it is a
different model trying to make money
just as a youtuber and advertising that
even the biggest guys have found other
ways to make money through brand deals
and other other avenues and just doing
it from advertising right elite focus
entertainment have either of you release
an e-book through kindle and if so how
is the experience have you done the
e-book I have not done any book any book
either yeah I've thought about it but
I'm not sure I just not haven't been
inspired I don't know if my book will
end up being an e-book I guess it
probably will through kindle it could be
yes I'm writing the book with penguin
Random House uh and I guess when that's
done it's going to be as for sure gonna
be an Amazon and probably an e-book so
yeah I think they would offer that's for
Kindle come back when my book is
launched and I could you but as of right
now I don't have an answer I think for
me like the book is to be like why do
you want to write a book I know I don't
want to write a book I never want to
write a book I don't like writing but
some people want it like you don't need
a book as much as you did before like a
book could get you in the door but could
get you speaking gigs a book they look
at my book you know its authority it's a
sign of respect and accomplishment where
I think now it's less important rather I
show people my youtube channel stay here
and I can line up an interview without
needing a book I get gigs without
meeting the book yeah so but some people
want to write a book just for a personal
reason like it's their life it's on
their bucket list of things to do right
I want to write a book hey then if you
don't even need a publisher for that
right you just sorry you have your
bundles yeah so just depends on your
goals um I'm doing a book because there
was a big publisher involve I didn't get
a publisher I wasn't gonna write a book
for sure did not want that to happen but
I got a publisher so I want someone's
going to like be committed to helping
get this thing out and they were so yeah
what's another avenue for you to reach
entrepreneurs and help them right that's
because that's your main goal yeah it
supports them the mission to reach of
the
entrepreneurs right so um that's why I'm
doing it yeah one more question from
Katie the only thing about hangouts is
that if you use the side chat these
comments and questions aren't shown
after the video is published it's true
and it bothers me uh I don't know if you
can see cuz I don't think you're
watching along but on the video there's
a little chat on the side where people
are typing these questions and I can
respond and then I asked do yeah once
that video goes live those comments
aren't shown as comments I could just
disappear here it's super annoying it's
super annoying i don't know why I've had
some where it's like a hundred comments
and questions come in and then when the
video goes live it shows 0 comments it's
starting all over from scratch um so yes
Katie I feel your pain I don't like it
either and the gin when you start doing
your hangouts you will experience the
same issue in front cool okay so i'm
going to write down one job and I'm not
111 copywriting per week and one jealous
important / hang out / personal / book
per week it's a good fit that's good
this I mean yes I'm committed okay i'm
looking forward to seen how many videos
i guess in another month we'll have two
per week so you got a video yes oh no
wow i'm excited that's probably the most
i would have another yeah how many of
you have total on your channel that
maybe like a good chunk of them actually
how because you have let you hide all
your daily one so you had something yeah
I had my daily book one so i think i
have over 50 now but most of those i
think about 30 of those are the book
ones well yeah very cool well have a
great month thank you sounds good